.
Dieser Teerplatz im Berner
Breitenrainquartier muss weg.
* Treibende Klänge *
Der erste Teil
ist immer der Abbruch.
Nächste Woche
ist der Abbruch vorbei,
dann beginnen wir zu gestalten.
Es war ein Wettbewerb
von Stadtgrün,
also von der Fachstelle
Natur und Ökologie.
Wir waren zu fünft und dachten uns:
"Da machen wir mit."
Wir hatten dann Glück
und haben gewonnen.
Es sind 90 m2 geteerte Fläche.
Das ist über längere Zeit
ein Problem in den Städten
mit den immer heisseren Sommern.
In den Städten ist es nachts
jetzt schon etwa 6 °C wärmer
als auf dem Land.
Das eine ist die Hitzereduktion,
das andere das Wasser.
Das Wasser soll im Boden versickern
und nicht
in der Kanalisation landen.
Hat dieses Ding eine Bremse?
- Nein, es hat keine.
Also dann.
Das ist für mich eigentlich
das Wichtigste am ganzen Projekt,
dass der Teer wegkommt.
Soll ich mal?
- Gerne. Sehr gerne.
* Rattern *
Juhu!
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
* Treibende Klänge *
Katrin Morina ist Gärtnerin
und wohnt zusammen mit 18 anderen
in diesem WG-Haus.
Sie hat das Projekt initiiert
und setzt es um.
Die Stadt
steuert 7'500 Fr. Preisgeld bei.
Das war der Auslöser, dass wir
am Wettbewerb teilgenommen haben.
Es gab dann schon
viele Diskussionen.
Wir mussten auch erklären,
wie man nachher
einen solchen Platz pflegt.
Man überlässt ihn
ja dann nicht sich selbst.
In den Bereichen,
die man sauber haben will,
recht man dann halt Laub,
statt zu fegen.
* Treibende Klänge *
Ein paar ihrer WG-Genossen
waren zuerst gar nicht begeistert.
Für die Kinder ist es ideal,
um Rad zu fahren, Hockey,
Fussball, Basketball zu spielen.
Darum war ich eher etwas skeptisch.
Aber irgendwie dünkte mich auch,
es sind andere Zeiten,
darauf muss ich mich einlassen.
Jetzt freue ich mich.
Es hat hier noch Bauschutt,
der weg muss.
Mittlerweile hat Katrin
alle WG-Bewohner an Bord.
Ich glaube, es ist ein Umdenken.
Generell ist es auch so,
dass der Biotrend zunimmt.
Da gehören diese Dinge ja auch dazu.
Also ich hoffe ganz fest,
dass dem so ist.
60 % aller Böden in den Siedlungs-
gebieten sind mit Teer versiegelt.
Und jedes Jahr kommen
neue Siedlungsflächen hinzu.
* Glockenläuten *
Pro Sekunde geht in der Schweiz
fast 1 m2 Naturfläche verloren.
In dieser Siedlung
in Meisterschwanden
bewohnt Familie Küffner
seit drei Jahren eine Dachwohnung.
Dort drüben ist die Gemeinde,
da ist der Siedlungsraum.
Und diese grosse Fläche
ist nicht begehbar,
aber trotzdem begrünt -
ungestört von Menschen und Katzen.
Auch Vögel hätten hier ein Gebiet,
in dem sie kaum gestört würden.
Eine ideale Fläche,
die man noch etwas interessanter
gestalten könnte.
Marianne Küffner
und ihre Tochter Katharina
haben bei der Gemeinde nachgefragt.
Ich habe sie einfach angeschrieben
und hoffte auf eine Reaktion.
Eigentlich mit wenig Hoffnung.
Ich dachte nicht,
dass sie sich melden.
Und dann sagten sie,
dies sei
eine sehr interessante Sache.
Sie würden unser Konzept
mit dem Hauseigentümer anschauen
und dafür sorgen,
dass der Gemeinderat darüber berät.
Nächste Woche
müssen sie das Konzept abgeben.
Schauen wir nochmals kurz,
was noch fehlt!
Ich habe übrigens noch eine Liste
von der Vogelwarte Sempach gefunden.
Da, dieser Ausdruck.
Es gibt Sträucher, die
für viele Vögel interessant sind,
z.B. der Vogelbeerbaum.
Hier haben wir noch den Dachaufbau.
1'700 m2 - viel grösser,
als wir gedacht haben.
Hier können wir
gewisse Sachen pflanzen,
die wertvoll sind für Bienen,
Insekten und evtl. sogar Vögel.
Wir haben nicht
so viele Grünflächen.
Katharina will Biologin werden.
Die sind natürlich ideal.
Ja.
Wir müssen noch
die Kosten zusammentragen.
Da bekommen wir ja Hilfe,
damit wir einen Kostenrahmen haben.
Wie kommen wir ...
- Über den Zaun.
Hilfe kommt von Landschaftsgärtner
Dominique Schmuki.
Er hat sich mit seinem Betrieb
auf Biodiversität spezialisiert.
Du kommst schon rüber, nicht?
Dürfen wir das?
- Ja.
Haben wir gefragt?
Es wird
ein Blähschiefer-Humus-Gemisch sein.
Wir haben sehr gute Voraussetzungen,
die wir hier schon benutzen können.
Die Bepflanzung ist etwas eintönig.
Es sind nicht gerade
die Favoriten der Wildbienen.
Aber es ist ein gutes Fundament,
auf dem man aufbauen kann.
Auf diese Weise
könnte man einen Hügel machen.
Man muss einfach darauf achten,
dass es von der Vegetation
nicht zugewuchert wird.
Ein paar Pflanzen sind in Ordnung,
aber es sollte nicht dicht werden.
Das wäre optimal für die Wildbienen.
Knapp 75 % der Wildbienenarten
nisten im Boden.
Damit kann man den Wildbienen
am besten helfen.- Tipptopp.
Hochgerechnet hätte es auf den Däch-
ern in der Schweiz 30-50 km2 Fläche,
die man besser begrünen könnte.
Sie haben
eher mediterrane Kräuter ausgesucht.
Das ist ökologisch
nicht allzu wertvoll.
Also ...
Für die Kräuterküche wäre sie super,
aber für die Insekten nicht.
Die geplanten Veränderungen
werden etwas kosten.
Man rechnet je nach Pflanze
mit zehn bis 20 Pflanzen
pro Quadratmeter.
Bei 1'700 m2
sind das ein paar Pflanzen.
Eine Pflanze kostet um die 7 Fr.
Da kommt
dann schon einiges zusammen.
Das Aussäen wird sicher stattfinden,
aber ich werde sicher
auch Initialpflanzungen machen,
damit die Pflanzen
weiter versamen können
und man etwas fürs Auge hat.
Das hilft sicher.
Total rechnet Schmuki mit Kosten
von mehreren Zehntausend Franken.
In den letzten 35 Jahren hat
die Siedlungsfläche in der Schweiz
um 25 % zugenommen.
Auch Regionen wie das Sarganserland
wurden stark zugebaut.
Landschaftsgärtner Edwin Bigger
geht für mehr Biodiversität
unkonventionelle Wege.
Ich hatte als Gärtner
ein Grundstück von ca. 1'600 m2,
auf dem ich der Natur
freien Lauf gelassen habe.
Das wurde natürlich von den Leuten
ein bisschen komisch angeschaut,
dass da ein Gärtner kommt
und gar nichts macht.
Der Bauernsohn
hat dieses Stück Land gekauft
und darauf
alte Obstsorten angepflanzt.
Wir haben es jetzt
zwei Jahre gar nicht gepflegt,
bzw. nur dort eingegriffen,
wo es nötig war -
wie jetzt bei diesen Brombeeren,
die momentan ziemlich wuchern.
Wir wollten auch schauen, welche
Pflanzenarten sich ausbreiten.
Man sieht hier
den Braunen Storchschnabel,
der extrem Überhand genommen hat.
Er hatte
mit der Trockenheit kein Problem
und ist sehr gutes Bienenfutter.
Das sind alte Sorten,
hauptsächlich von ProSpecieRara.
Wir wollen wieder
aromahaltige Fruchtbäume haben,
damit die Leute wieder lernen,
was Geschmack ist,
und nicht auf die fünf Sorten
im Regal zurückgreifen müssen.
In der Schweiz hatten wir
über 700 Apfelsorten im Inventar.
Auf alten Fotos
von den Dörfern in der Region
sieht man überall
nur Obstgärten mit Hochstämmern.
Mitte 50er- bis Mitte 80er-Jahre
wurde diese gefällt,
wobei man vom Bund
eine Fällprämie erhalten hatte.
In dieser Zeit
ging sehr viel Genpool verloren,
was heute dem biologischen Landbau
sehr dienen würde.
Jetzt läuft's wieder umgekehrt:
Die Bepflanzung mit Hochstämmern
wird subventioniert,
aber es wird 15 Jahre dauern,
bis man Vollerträge hat.
* Rauschen des Windes *
Im Auftrag der Stadt Sargans
gestaltet Edwin Bigger den
Aussenbereich eines Kindergartens um.
Dafür hat er
einen Magerwiesenbereich definiert.
Biodiversität funktioniert nur, wenn
der Boden nicht zu viel Humus hat.
Wir haben den Boden abgemagert.
Wir säen jetzt hauptsächlich
nur Blumen - ohne Gräser -
und schauen, was für ein Bestand
aus dem Spontanbewuchs der Gräser
entsteht.
Wenn es dann nötig wäre, würden wir
auch ein paar wenige Gräser säen.
Wichtig ist, dass die Blumen
am Anfang Licht haben.
An der Eröffnung vor zwei Monaten
sah es noch anders aus.
Das Ziel
von Stadtpräsident Jörg Tanner:
Sargans soll die biodiverseste Stadt
der Schweiz werden.
Heute ist der Startschuss
beim Kindergarten Grünau.
Wir dürfen als Pilotgemeinde
eine Vorreiterrolle spielen.
Wir wollen auch andere Gemeinden,
vielleicht auch andere Kantone
und den Bund,
mit diesem Projekt motivieren,
dass sie den gleichen Pfad
einschlagen wie wir auch.
Hier sind diverse Flächen abgebildet
samt einem Pflegeplan,
wie man die Biodiversitätsstrategie
umsetzen könnte.
Edwin Bigger setzt mit den Kindern
nur einheimische Sträucher ein,
die verschiedensten Insekten
Futter bieten sollen.
Das ist schon mal gut.
Jetzt hier rein.
Super.
Hier könnt ihr auch noch graben.
Das mache ich.
Nein, ich will.
- Es geht auch mit den Händen.
Man muss auch ein wenig provozieren.
Vielleicht
finden es einige etwas extrem,
dass ich nur
einheimische Pflanzen setze.
Aber man muss ja
irgendwann mal was bewegen
und darum
auch ein bisschen radikal sein.
Es gibt sehr wesentliche Punkte,
die geändert werden sollten,
damit es grüner werden kann -
z.B. im Kanton St. Gallen
die Grenzabstände der Bäume.
Man baut immer näher,
das lässt man zu,
aber nicht,
dass man die Bäume näher pflanzt.
Irgendwo muss man beginnen,
findet Jörg Tanner.
Der Kindergarten
sei ein guter Anfang.
Der Weg mit den Kindern
über die Schüler,
damit die Eltern aktiv werden
und sich auch überlegen,
was man zu Hause zusammen
mit den Kindern machen könnte,
ich glaube, das ist ein Prozess
wie in der Schule,
wo man Mathe oder Deutsch lernt.
Und das wollen wir hier
eigentlich gleich durchziehen.
Eins, zwei, drei! Hopp!
Der ist nicht so schwer.
- Ich falle gleich noch hin.
Sargans bietet seinen Einwohnern
auch die Möglichkeit,
fremdländische Sträucher gratis
gegen einheimische einzutauschen.
Und auf dem Schlosshügel setzt
die Gemeinde gegen invasive Neophyten
neuerdings Geissen ein.
* Perlende Klänge *
Auch in der Landwirtschaft
ist Sensibilisierung wichtig.
Wiese ist nicht gleich Wiese,
vielerorts ist die Artenvielfalt
massiv zurückgegangen.
Der WWF
hat einen Wettbewerb lanciert,
um die schönsten Magerwiesen
im Kanton Zürich zu prämieren.
Jetzt laufen wir dort runter.
- Ja, das ist der Baum. Jawohl.
Jetzt sind wir im B.
Davon bin ich
noch nicht ganz überzeugt.
Jede dritte Tier- und Pflanzenart
ist bedroht.
Wir haben nicht mehr unendlich
viel Zeit, um das Artenpotenzial,
das wir hier noch haben,
zu erhalten.
Vor 100 Jahren gab es
im Kanton Zürich noch etwa 30'000 ha
solch schöner magerer Wiese,
und heute sind es noch 150, 200 ha.
Mehr als 99 % dieser Flächen
sind verschwunden.
Es ist wirklich dramatisch.
* Zirpen *
Wunderbar! Das ist eine Grille,
eine Feldgrille.
Da sieht man wieder, wie wichtig
die offenen Bodenstellen sind.
Sie sucht jetzt wahrscheinlich
wieder ihre Höhle.- Genau.
Ranunculus bulbosus.
- Knolliger Hahnenfuss.
Und dann der Purpursteinsame,
Buglossoides purpurocaerulea.
Der wurde ganz offensichtlich
eingesät, davon gehe ich jetzt aus.
Eine wirkliche Magerwiesen
hat oben Gras und unten Kräuter.
Sie hat wenig Biomasse,
aber viel Biodiversität.
Es braucht schon
grosse Anstrengungen,
um wirklich magere Wiesen
wieder fördern zu können.
Die Jury findet nicht nur
Erfreuliches auf den drei Wiesen,
die sie an diesem Tag bewerten muss.
Da haben wir den Bösewicht,
das einjährige Berufkraut.
Das Problem ist, dass,
wenn man es schneidet ...
Wenn es dort zu blühen beginnt
und man es schneidet,
dann macht es unten
drei bis fünf Triebe
und blüht innerhalb
von zwei Wochen wieder. Grausam.
Der Rehe fressen es auch ab.
Und dann kommt es gleich wieder,
das ist wahnsinnig!
Das ist wirklich ein echtes Problem.
Invasive Neophyten verbreiten sich
seit ein paar Jahren rasant.
Darum ist es wichtig, dass die Bauern
solche Naturwiesen pflegen.
Man muss aufpassen, sonst wird
noch das Falsche ausgerissen.
Ich verdiene etwas damit,
also ist es für mich
keine unlukrative Wiese.
Aber nicht wegen des Futters,
sondern wegen der Direktzahlungen.
Martin Maag bekommt pro Hektare
ca. 3'000 Fr.
Insgesamt leistet der Bund
ökologische Ausgleichszahlungen
von jährlich 400 Mio. Fr.
René.
Trifolium .... Trifolium campestre.
Campestre?
- Ja, campestre.
Wenn man bestimmte Arten
fördern will,
die verschwunden
oder stark zurückgegangen sind,
braucht es mehr als nur
ökologische Ausgleichsflächen.
Bis jetzt hat der Bund das Ziel
für 2020 noch nicht erreicht.
Statt 17 % biodiverser Förderfläche -
wie international verlangt -
gibt's im Moment in der Schweiz
erst 12,5 %.
Das ist Fuchsi, Fuchs' Knabenkraut.
Mit den gefleckten Blättern.
Relativ schmale, gefleckte Blätter.
Hier hat es
einen schönen Bestand davon.
Die Daten
sind für uns auch wertvoll,
weil es ein Inventar
der guten Wiesen ist und wir denken,
dass wir sie künftig auch für
Direktbegrünungen brauchen können.
Wir möchten ja auch neue Wiesen
mit regionalem Saatgut begrünen.
Und jetzt wissen wir,
wo die besten Flächen sind.
Von 10'000 bewerteten Tier-
und Pflanzenarten in der Schweiz
sind 35 % bedroht -
das ist deutlich mehr als
in den anderen europäischen Ländern
und liegt u.a. auch an der
industriellen Saatgutproduktion.
Auf vielen Wiesen
wächst heute das Gleiche.
Direktbegrünungen mit solch gutem,
regionalem und biodiversem Saatgut
könnten das korrigieren.
* Perlende Klänge *
Küffners sind gespannt,
ob die Gemeinde
ihr Dachbegrünungsprojekt finanziert.
Die Gemeinde Meisterschwanden
hat das diskutiert.
Es braucht immer Geld.
Für dieses Projekt
wäre das Geld sichergestellt.
Die Gemeinde würde das
vollumfänglich finanzieren,
damit es umgesetzt werden kann.
So schön.
Danke.
Man kann die Natur nicht kaufen,
nur etwas dazu beitragen.
Es soll in der Schweiz ja nicht so
weit kommen wie in anderen Ländern,
dass wir selbst bestäuben müssen.
Aber die Schweiz
muss ein bisschen Vorreiter sein,
weil wir Möglichkeiten haben,
die andere Länder nicht haben.
30'000 Fr. darf es kosten,
aber man gewinnt dafür
auch ein gewisses Know-how.
Von Biodiversität
haben wir noch nicht viel Ahnung.
Darum wären wir froh, wenn ihr
bei der Ausführung den Lead hättet,
natürlich zusammen
mit den Initianten.
Angedacht von der Gemeinde wäre,
dass wir euch
das Bauamt als Beihilfe
zur Verfügung stellen würden.
Nicht alle beim Bauamt sind
jetzt schon begeistert vom Projekt.
Die sagen natürlich:
"Jetzt kommt es aber knüppeldick."
"Was müssen wir jetzt noch?"
Und, und, und.
Das muss fruchten,
das geht nicht von heute auf morgen.
Ich bin überzeugt, wenn man die
ersten positiven Ergebnisse sieht,
ändert sich die Einstellung dazu.
Zur Pflanzenmischung:
Ist das eine Standardmischung,
eine UFA-Blumenwiesenmischung,
oder was müssen wir uns
darunter vorstellen?
Wir nehmen Impfmischungen.
D.h., wir nehmen Schnittgut
von einem anderen Flachdach
und verteilen es, damit sich
die Samen hier etablieren können.
Als Brunnenmeister
würde mich auch interessieren:
Was heisst das für die Bewässerung
einer solchen Anlage?
Ziel ist eigentlich,
dass man nicht bewässern muss.
Die Pflanzenauswahl wird so gesetzt,
dass sie die Trockenheit überstehen.
Ziel ist wirklich,
dass man nicht wässern muss.
Auch nicht auf einem solchen Dach?
- Nein.
Im Herbst
will Landschaftsgärtner Schmuki
mit der ersten Bepflanzung beginnen.
Es könnte eine Inspiration
für viele andere Gärten sein.
Vielleicht
könnte man auch organisieren,
dass Besucher vorbeikommen
und schauen können,
was man machen könnte und sie
in ihrem Garten machen könnten.
* Lebhafte Musik *
Hier herrscht noch ein Chaos
vor dem Haus mit Schutt.
Der Teer ist weg, aber es
gab eine unliebsame Überraschung.
Die Entsorgung des Teers
ist deutlich teurer.
Ich weiss aber noch nicht genau,
was es jetzt kostet.
Er ist PAK-belastet
und musste sonderentsorgt werden.
Rund 5'000 Fr.
kostet die Sonderentsorgung.
Das nervt, aber Katrin
versteht umgekehrt auch nicht,
warum die Leute immer meinen,
Aussenraumpflege sei gratis.
Wenn man im Haus
irgendwas ändert oder macht,
ist man mit den Beträgen
sehr schnell in dieser Höhe.
Und Gärten sind ja Räume,
die unheimlich wichtig sind.
Die meisten Menschen
halten sich ja im Sommer
auf ihren Balkonen
und in ihren Gärten auf.
Morgen.
Deine Frau hat hart gearbeitet.
Ich habe gesehen, wie sie
die Platten runtergetragen hat.
Das ist ein harter Job.
Es ist auf alle Fälle
um Welten besser als der Asphalt.
Ich wünsche Ihnen
weiterhin einen guten Tag.
Genormte Platten gibt's nur dort,
wo es nötig ist.
Die Reaktionen sind gut,
ich freue mich.
Ich glaube auch,
weil wir das selbst machen,
weil viele Frauen am Arbeiten sind,
kommt das gut rüber.
Ich möchte hier einen gemischten
Platz mit Gneisplatten wie da vorne.
Und dann haben wir
hier noch das Mäuerchen,
das vor dem Haus war,
das wir jetzt recyceln.
Und dann haben wir noch
Pflastersteine geschenkt bekommen.
Und Pflastersteine, die ich
selbst auf die Seite getan habe.
Jetzt gibt es
eine Art Recyclingplatz
mit Natur- und neuen Steinen,
denn diese Menge Material haben wir
nicht einfach so auftreiben können.
Ich denke, es dauert noch zwei Tage,
bis der Platz fertig ist.
In der Nähe von Sargans
führt Edwin Bigger eine Baumschule.
Er lässt den Pflanzen Raum und
greift nur ein, wo es notwendig ist.
Die Aussenfläche eines Gartens
widerspiegelt für mich,
ganz bös gesagt,
ein bisschen den Dialog,
den die entsprechende Person,
die dort wohnt, mit der Natur führt.
Und wenn ich diesen Spiegel sehe,
bin ich oft mehr als schockiert,
weil man sich
gar nicht mehr mit dem Thema
oder unserem Ursprung auf der Erde
befasst.
Auf Pestizide verzichtet Bigger ganz.
Am Anfang wollte er ausschliesslich
auf inländischen
und naturnahen Gartenbau setzen.
Ich bin von Bern zurückgekommen
und wollte diesen grünen Faktor
eigentlich mehr aufleben lassen
mit einheimischen Pflanzen,
habe aber gemerkt,
dass man hier
noch nicht ganz bereit ist -
das war vor zwölf Jahren.
Trotzdem hat er mit biodiverser
Bepflanzung weitergemacht.
Wir haben festgestellt, dass
die Verschiedenartigkeit dazu führt,
dass wir praktisch keinen
Schädlingsbefall mehr haben.
Letztes Jahr, als es so heiss war,
haben wir alles im Freiland
gar nicht bewässert
und nur zwei Bäume sind ausgefallen.
Die Felder und Wiesen rundherum
waren braun,
und hier drin hatten wir
eigentlich keine Schäden,
weil wir den Boden bedeckt
und organische Masse hatten.
Wir haben in der Bepflanzung,
in der Unterpflanzung,
in den Begleitkräutern,
wie man sagt, auch Nützlinge drin,
die Unterschlupf finden
und dann schon vor Ort sind,
wenn negative Aspekte,
Läuse oder andere Schädlinge,
bereits vorhanden sind.
Sie verhindern, dass sich
die Läuse verbreiten können.
Gegen Läuse helfen Marienkäfer,
aber auch Wespen.
Wir haben im ganzen Gewächshaus
Feldwespen.
Ihre Nester haben keine Ummantelung.
Jetzt sieht man gerade den Wächter,
der vorne schaut.
Sie sind relativ friedfertig.
Bei so nahen Bewegungen würden
normale Wespen schon lange kommen,
sie schauen ein bisschen, was läuft.
Sie halten uns
sehr viele Schädlinge fern,
z.B. wenn ein Lausbestand
aufkommen sollte,
denn ihre Larven füttern sie
mit Protein und nicht mit Zucker.
* Perlende Klänge *
Erdbeeren!
- Die musst du noch sein lassen.
Mittlerweile
hat es auch im Sarganserland
immer mehr Leute,
die Edwin Biggers Ideen gut finden.
Caroline Bell hat vor einem Jahr
den Garten ihres Einfamilienhauses
neu gestaltet.
Bigger hat sie überzeugt, viele
verschiedene Pflanzen zu setzen.
Was hier wegen der Sonne bereits
geschlossen ist, ist Echter Lein.
Die Kügelchen an der Pflanze
sind Leinsamen.
Das ist eine alte Kulturpflanze,
die wir für den Ziereffekt
reingetan haben.
Das ist eine der Pflanzen,
die wir gesetzt haben,
damit sie sich selbst ausbreitet
und die Lücken von alleine füllt.
Die Pflanzen mit dieser Wirkung
sind lichthungrig.
Sobald was anderes, was dort
geplant war, dominanter wird,
verschwinden diese Pflanzen
von alleine wieder.
Somit kommt dann das angedachte Bild
wieder zum Vorschein.
Caroline Bell wollte v.a.,
dass es immer blüht.
Man sieht ja schon im Kleinen,
was man machen kann
und was man dann alles hat.
Wir sind jetzt
den vierten Sommer hier.
Vorher hatten wir nur Rasen,
sonst eigentlich nichts.
Jetzt haben wir Bienen, Hummeln -
es lebt einfach.
Es ist wirklich faszinierend,
was das ausmacht.
Es ist schon eindrücklich,
was man mit Bepflanzung
erreichen kann.
Bigger will seinen Kunden zeigen,
dass ihre Gärten auch ohne Gift
schön und pflegeleicht sein können.
In diesen Privatgärten
oder Schrebergärten
hat es oftmals mehr Chemie drin
als in der Landwirtschaft,
die produziert.
Denn Private
gehen oft falsch damit um.
Wenn ein Herbizid oder Insektizid
angewendet wird,
was seit 2007
auf vielen Flächen verboten ist,
dann wird es
noch ein bisschen höher dosiert,
damit es auch sicher wirkt.
Es sind geschulte Leute,
die diese Rezepturen
zusammengestellt
und das Produkt
auf den Markt gebracht haben.
Wenn überhaupt, sollte man es
so anwenden wie beschrieben,
damit es die nötige Wirkung hat
und nicht mehr Schaden
als Wirkung verursacht.
In der Schweiz gibt es
rund 1 Mio. Einfamilienhäuser
mit 200-500 Mio. m2 Gartenfläche
darum herum.
Davon könnten mind. 100 Mio. m2
biodiverser begrünt werden.
* Vergnügte Musik *
Das ist keine riesige Rabatte.
Aber es hat deutlich mehr Platz
für die Pflanzen
als vorhin in dieser Ecke.
Die WG hat sich organisiert -
immer ist jemand da, der hilft.
Ja, genau.
Dort unten in der unteren Ecke.
Salbei, ist klar.
Dort hinten
ist noch ein Bohnenkraut.
Da wollte ich einfach noch
einen Farbtupfer mit Echinacea.
Die habe ich noch gerettet, genau.
Jene, die noch gut aussehen,
kannst du dazwischen pflanzen.
Die hier lohnen sich nicht mehr,
aber alles,
was noch eine gute Blattmasse hat.
Die Löwenmäulchen
sorgen für Farbtupfer.
Katrin pflanzt alles ein,
was noch einigermassen lebt.
Am liebsten würde sie
nur einheimische Pflanzen nehmen,
aber das
hat sie nicht ganz geschafft.
Die kommt noch vors Haus,
aber dort hat es noch kein Loch.
Das ist eine Minikiwi.
Sie wächst gut im Halbschatten,
und die Früchte werden reif.
Die müssen hier
10 m in die Höhe wachsen.
Und sie sollten auch noch
ein bisschen dekorativ sein.
Davon haben wir nicht
sehr viele in der Schweiz.
Doch es gibt schon Pflanzen,
die sie gar nie setzen würde.
Kirschlorbeer ist immer noch etwas,
das viel zu viel gepflanzt wird.
Er ist invasiv, breitet sich z.T.
auch schon in unseren Wäldern aus.
Im Tessin sind die Wälder
schon ziemlich voll davon.
Er wird aber trotzdem
noch ziemlich häufig gepflanzt,
weil er halt immergrün ist
und nicht so viel kostet.
Kaum ist gepflanzt,
kommen neue Bewohner,
um Nestmaterial zu sammeln.
Da.
Mega herzig.
Erde ist sehr wertvoll.
Auch auf dem Kiesplatz ...
Da war immer irgendwo eine.
* Treibende Klänge *
So.
Jetzt schauen wir,
dass wir ihn so runterkippen können.
Die Baumstämme sind für die Insekten.
Sieht schön aus -
mit diesen Ästen, mit diesen Bäumen.
Mhm.
Katharina Küffner
hat in ihrem eigenen Dachgarten
ebenfalls ein Experiment laufen.
Sie hat Verschiedenes
durcheinander gepflanzt,
aber das Durcheinander hat System:
So funktioniert eine Permakultur.
Hier sind mal Bohnen gewachsen.
Aber weil Herbst ist,
sind sie nicht mehr da.
Das ist der Schichtenaufbau.
Sie spenden
den Pflanzen hier Schatten.
Weil ich hier sehr viel Sonne habe,
braucht es eine Pflanze,
die sehr viel Sonne verträgt
und den Pflanzen hier
im Sommer Schatten spendet.
Ich habe sie
im Sommer nie gegossen,
durch den Nebel oder Regen
haben sie sich selbst versorgt.
Nebst Peperoni, Himbeeren und Gurken
sind auch drei Melonen gewachsen.
Ich glaube, die ist bald mal reif.
Diese Pflanze
braucht extrem viel Wasser,
und das ist ein Problem,
das wir in Zukunft lösen müssen.
Aktuell
sterben 50 % unseres Waldes weg.
V.a. die Nadelbäume sind zu trocken,
von Käfern befallen, krank.
Momentan
werden überall Bäume gefällt.
Es wird geraten,
Mischwald aufzubauen,
also wieder zu beginnen,
verschiedene Sorten zu mischen,
damit der Boden
nicht ausgelaugt wird
und das Wasser
besser gespeichert werden kann.
Denn das Wasser
kommt nicht nur durch den Regen,
sondern auch durch die Feuchtigkeit
in der Nacht,
die auf der Erde
nur gebunden werden muss.
So müssen wir nicht
stets auf den Regen warten,
der immer weniger wird.
Bei den Menschen
muss ein Umdenken stattfinden.
Es wird nicht mehr so einfach sein,
Monokulturen anzupflanzen,
denn die brauchen
viel zu viel Wasser.
Auf dem Dach nebenan baut
Dominique Schmuki eine Wasserstelle.
Es braucht nicht
das ganze Jahr Wasser.
Wir passen es noch etwas an,
und hier drin
werden auch noch Pflanzen wachsen.
Aussen setzen wir Pflanzen,
die sich nach innen versamen können.
Nur Pflanzen,
die Feuchtigkeit mögen,
siedeln sich dann hier drin an.
Das Wasser dient natürlich auch
als Trinkwasser für heisse Tage,
damit auch die Insekten
etwas trinken können.
Normalerweise muss man immer
auf die Bedürfnisse der Menschen
Rücksicht nehmen,
aber bei einer solchen Fläche
kann man mal nur
auf Tiere und Pflanzen achten.
So macht es umso mehr Spass,
etwas zu gestalten
und die Entwicklung zu beobachten:
Wer siedelt sich an,
wie verbreitet es sich?
Dort drüben haben wir mehr Platz.
Du kannst ihn mal runterlassen.
Das sollte so funktionieren.
Es sind gegen 750 kleine Pflanzen.
750 Pflanzen?
- Jawohl.
Und es sind
sechs Arten von Sträuchern.
Wir haben viele brachliegende
Flächen in der Gemeinde,
wo wir solche Projekte
starten wollen.
Beim alten Gemeindehaus soll neu
Magerwiese angepflanzt werden -
auch um erste Erfahrungen zu sammeln
und unsere Werkbetriebe
da heranführen zu können.
Insgesamt sind es knapp 100 Arten,
kunterbunt durchmischt.
Von Anfang bis Ende Jahr
soll immer etwas am Blühen sein,
von Februar bis Oktober
soll immer etwas am Blühen sein.
Ein paar Sachen kennen wir, ja.
Also die Wilde Möhre
sieht aus wie ...
Sie macht eine weisse Blüte,
in der Mitte aber eine dunkle Blüte,
die einen Käfer imitiert,
der auf der Blüte ist.
Die Wilde Möhre.
Das ist Thymian.
Der wächst wie ein Teppich.
Das ist natürlich interessant.
Das ist einheimischer Thymian.
- Okay.
Wir achten darauf, möglichst nur
einheimische Pflanzen zu setzen.
Das sind eigentlich
die einzigen nicht-einheimischen.
Warum?
Die Wollbiene
benutzt sie als Nestbaumaterial.
Wenn sie ein Nest baut,
nagt sie diese Fasern ab.
Sie braucht dann den Wollknäuel,
um ihr Nest zu bauen.
Bienen leisten zwei Drittel
der Bestäubungsarbeit.
Doch die Hälfte der 600 Bienenarten
in der Schweiz ist bedroht.
Fliegen sind auch Bestäuber, Bienen
sind nicht die einzigen Bestäuber.
Auch Wespen, Schwebfliegen
und normale Fliegen sind Bestäuber,
aber auch Stechmücken.
Das wissen die meisten Leute nicht.
Sie sind halt
nicht nur Plagegeister,
sondern auch wichtige Akteure
im Ökosystem.
Sieht cool aus.
Da wir nur einen haben,
pflanze ich ihn in der Mitte.
Und jetzt könnt ihr anfangen,
die Pflanzen zu verteilen.
Wie hast du den rausgekriegt?
Hast du das aufgerissen?
Man kriegt sie
nur schwer aus dem Topf.
Wenn alles eingepflanzt ist, müssen
sich die drei erst mal gedulden,
bis es wieder wärmer wird.
So. Done.
Im Frühling
will Dominique den Rest ansäen.
Der Gartenumbau in Bern ist fertig.
Weisst du, wo der Igel wohnt?
Der Projektleiter von Stadtgrün Bern,
der den Wettbewerb begleitet hat,
lässt sich das Resultat zeigen.
Ah, dort, der Mauer entlang.
- Hier siehst du ihn.
Es braucht eben nicht viel.
- Einfach nicht zu fest aufräumen.
Hier waren jeweils Junge unterwegs
und haben in den Spalten
etwas gesucht.
Bezüglich Temperatur
gibt es Messungen, die zeigen,
dass es gut 4-5 °C Unterschied
ausmachen kann
im Vergleich
zu einer versiegelten Fläche.
Ein versiegelter Boden
speichert die Wärme tagsüber
und gibt sie dann langsam wieder ab.
Das trägt in der Nacht
nicht zur Verdunstung bei.
Eine unversiegelte Fläche
hat ein Verdunstungspotenzial,
und Verdunstung heisst Kühlung.
Das ist der stadtklimatische Aspekt.
Zudem kann das Wasser
im Boden versickern
und muss nicht
kompliziert entwässert werden.
Es gibt auch Messungen, die zeigen,
dass Fassadenbegrünungen
extrem effizient sind.
Da gibt es Berechnungen,
die aufzeigen,
dass an einem Tag,
an dem es 32 °C warm ist,
die Aussenmauer eines Gebäudes
aus Beton 45 °C warm ist
und hinter einer begrünten Fassade
die gleiche Mauer nur noch 32 °C.
Alles nur ein Tropfen
auf den heissen Stein, sagen viele.
Solange die Regenwälder brennen,
nütze alles nichts.
Der Amazonas ist weit weg,
da ist viel Ohnmacht vorhanden.
Aber hier kann man was machen,
das sofort eine Wirkung entfaltet.
Und wenn das viele machen,
dann bringt es eben was -
und es macht auch noch glücklich.
Die Nachbarn
sind zur Gartenparty eingeladen.
Du kannst ihn mit Lehm füllen,
wenn du willst.
Wo ist der kleine Löffel?
Die Kinder machen Samenbomben
für die Gäste.
Wir haben zwei Wildbienenmischungen.
Die hier ist für Balkonkistchen,
wenn man Erde hat,
die sehr nährstoffreich ist.
Und die hier
ist für schattigen Garten.
Willst du?
Nicht?
Ich glaube, ich tue sie
auf dem Balkon in ein Töpfchen.
Die sind so schön.
- Die sind auch Wahnsinn.
Katrin zeigt ihren WG-Kolleginnen
mit einem selbst gemachten Memory,
was alles wachsen wird.
Sind das Nelken?
- Ja, Waldnelken.
Und die ist wirklich pink.
Und wo ist sie?
Die ist dort hinten an zwei Orten.
Und du schaust jetzt
zu all diesen Pflanzen?
Giessen können wir ja auch.
- Also ich muss nichts tun?
Ich muss nicht so viel tun,
nur entfernen, was nebenan wächst,
die Beikräuter, die zu gross werden.
In der hintersten schattigen Ecke
ist noch ein Farn,
ein Wald-Frauenfarn.
Und die sind so schön,
das sind Hügelanemonen.
Hallo, Nils. Schön, dass du kommst.
- Ich bin gespannt.
Wie gefällt es dir?
- Die Bilder sehen gut aus.
Nein!
Sie meint den Garten.
- Habe ihn noch nicht gesehen.
Willst du ihn dir ansehen?- Ja.
- Ja, klar.
Also.
Dort hinten ...
... leider schon etwas verdorrt
und hier etwas umgeknickt ...
Das sind Weidenröschen.
Sie blühen rosarot,
sollten aufrecht stehen,
was sie nächstes Jahr
auch tun werden.
Sie werden die Ecke ziemlich füllen.
Das sieht alles
noch so unscheinbar aus.
Ich bin gespannt,
wie es auf der Mauer aussieht.
Das ist immer so,
wenn es neu gepflanzt ist.
Ich weiss noch nicht, was das ist.
Das ist irgendwas,
das noch in der Erde war.
* Pulsierende Klänge *
Acht Monate sind vergangen -
es ist Mai.
Dominique Schmuki ist erleichtert,
dass der trockene Frühling
seinen Pflanzen
auf dem Dach in Meisterschwanden
nicht geschadet hat.
Es hat trotz grosser Trockenheit
sehr viel überlebt.
Wir haben nie gewässert.
Es ist sehr viel durchgekommen
und sieht prächtig aus.
Wasser hat es nicht viel,
aber es reicht,
um die Feuchtigkeit für die
Wasserpflanzen zu gewährleisten.
Die pinkfarbene Kuckucks-Lichtnelke
ist wunderschön am Blühen.
Und die kleinen Pfützen geben gutes
Trinkwasser für Vögel und Insekten.
Ziel erreicht, ich bin zufrieden.
Auch Marianne Küffner
hat ihr Ziel erreicht.
Schön, wie alles gewachsen ist.
Schritt für Schritt
konnte man es beobachten.
Das Schönste ist das Zusammenspiel
und dass es so divers ist.
Man sieht v.a. bestehende Pflanzen,
die schon drin waren.
Vereinzelt blühen auch
die neu gesetzten Pflanzen.
Ich habe letzten Herbst
noch ein paar Samen ausgesät,
und es sind hauptsächlich
zweijährige Pflanzen.
Die Königskerze beginnt jetzt,
Blütenstände zu machen.
Sie macht einen grossen Zapfen.
Und dann macht sie
sehr viele kleine Samen,
die sich in der Umgebung
zu Jungpflanzen entwickeln.
Und der Stängel der Königskerze,
der dann abgestorben ist,
wird von den Insekten gebraucht
als Nist- bzw. Überwinterungshilfe.
Schmuki sät noch Blumen an,
aber viel ist nicht mehr nötig.
Im hinteren Teil des Dachs
ist Klatschmohn gewachsen.
Das war Anfang Jahr
eine schöne Überraschung.
Ich gehe davon aus,
dass die Samen, also Mohn und
Kamille, im Substrat drin waren.
Die Natur zaubert immer wieder.
Schmuki wünscht sich, dass die
Menschen mehr Lust und Mut bekommen,
sich auf diesen Zauber einzulassen.
Es gibt nicht nur Biodiversität
mit Insekten und Pflanzen,
sondern auch
mit den verschiedenen Gärten.
Jeder Garten
hat seinen eigenen Charakter,
was auch zu einer Vielfalt führt.
Die Leute sind zuerst unsicher,
wenn ich will, dass sie gestalten,
aber wenn dann der Prozess beginnt,
sind sie sehr glücklich
und fühlen sich auch erfüllt.
Auch die Berner WG ist happy.
Ohne Teer
entsteht ein ganz neues Gartengefühl.
Wenn ich
das Schlussresultat betrachte,
bin ich recht begeistert.
Es hat an Lebensqualität gewonnen.
Es ist schön, hier zu verweilen.
Es ist weniger
das Bärengrabengefühl,
das ich vorher manchmal
hier im Hof hatte.
Und ich freue mich,
wenn dann noch die Pflanzen dem Haus
entlang gegen den Himmel steigen.
Wahrscheinlich in drei Jahren
wird sie oben sein
und dort drüben.
In diesem Jahr ist sie
schon mehr als 2 m gewachsen.
Drei bis fünf Jahre wird es dauern,
bis der ganze Garten
richtig bewachsen ist.
Es ist schon
sehr viel schöner geworden.
Es blüht überall.
Ich finde, man kümmert sich
auch recht gut darum.
Es macht Spass, es ist gut.
Der Eyecatcher
ist das begrünte Velodach.
Ziemlich viele Leute
sind begeistert, bleiben stehen
und nehmen einen Augenschein,
obwohl noch nicht so viel wächst.
Hier drin wächst
ein einjähriges Berufkraut.
Das ist eine invasive Neophyte.
Die kommt jetzt sofort raus,
bevor sie blüht und absamt.
Da hinten
ist eine Ecke mit Brennnesseln,
die sich hoffentlich
noch ein bisschen mehr ausbreiten.
Brennnesseln sind ja sehr wichtige
Pflanzen für Schmetterlinge.
Und jetzt
machen wir gar nichts mehr.
Wir werden weder wässern noch jäten
und schauen, was sich entwickelt.
Das Einzige, was wir machen,
ist Neophyten ausjäten.
Praktisch ist der neue Kräutergarten.
Wir kaufen keine Kräuter mehr,
es ist ja alles da.
Und das wird jetzt
auch wirklich genutzt.
Der neue Hinterhof
ist also nicht nur schön,
er ist in vielerlei Hinsicht
nützlich.
Und jäten muss Katrin
wirklich nur noch ausnahmsweise.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Philipp Schlatter - 2020